what we have showing here is the
ownership
and then the fires that we're currently
fighting he'd retweeted a climate change
denier on route to the wildfire zone
even here donald trump continues to defy
what the weight of science is saying
and blaming forest management here
doesn't wash
i think there's an area of at least
commonality on vegetation
forest management but please
respect and i know you do the difference
of opinion out here as it relates to
this fundamental issue
on the issue of climate change
absolutely because if we if we ignore
that science and sort of put our head in
the sand and think it's all about
vegetation management
we're not going to succeed together
protecting californians okay
it'll start getting cooler you just
watch
i wish science agreed with you oh well
i don't think science knows actually
this is political of course
in an election year his rival with the
polar opposite view
requires action not denial requires
leadership
not scapegoating it requires the
president
to meet the threshold duty of the office
to care
to care for everyone this is the reality
across hundreds of miles
thick smoke literally off the charts for
poor air quality
and in communities across the west this
a home and business now just embers the
everyday visible in the ruins
lives and livelihoods swept away in a
flash there are hundreds of homes now
like this
charred memorials to what was once here
and the terrible and growing cost of
wildfires
all neighbors could do was watch it burn
you could see the the glow from the fire
from my place i was
just at the top of my road checking it
out making sure it didn't make it any
further
me and my brother took turns all night
just two hour shifts
he would he would watch watch from the
top of the road for the first couple
hours
come wake me up and we'd take turns
because as soon as it got over the ridge
i mean we were probably gonna bowl
these scenes have become sadly very
familiar over the last few
years of wildfires on the west coast but
what's unprecedented about this
is where it's happening this is cooler
wetter oregon where the conditions for
wildfires
simply shouldn't exist locals will tell
you this kind of thing
doesn't happen here well it does now
search teams are now picking through the
ruins looking for signs of those
who didn't get out the number confirmed
dead is going up
the pink fire retardant streaked through
the debris
whatever the politics this is now real
life for so many
greg milam sky news oregon